2 mi nombre es del corre a tu nombre mi
nombre mío es se vacían mirando emails y
nosotros venimos del estudio de diseño
la casa de carlota el título se llama
ojo por ojo miro por el otro es hablaron
de cambio
estamos hablando desde un estudio de
diseño que es profesional que es un
negocio es pero que mira diferente que
estamos generando un real cambio porque
esto es nuestro equipo de diseño es una
es un estudio profesional que integra de
forma igual igual a jóvenes diseñadores
artistas con chicos con síndrome de down
con autismo y otras condiciones eso ya
lo hace bastante diferente entonces hoy
estamos sebastián y yo aquí pero
representamos a todo un equipo de
trabajo que está allí trabajando
profesional en nuestra agencia
entonces te das cuenta es a ellos tú
tienes síndrome de que me se mire mi
lado mío ese galán
caballero en el prisma y méxico y soy un
diseñador perfecto buenísimo sebastián
entonces para empezar vamos a contarles
un poquito de nuestra historia
esta idea inicia
cuando decidimos hacer un experimento y
decir por qué no integrar a jóvenes
diseñadores con chicos con estas
condiciones en igualdad de condiciones
entonces ese experimento que empieza en
barcelona del 2013 gracias a una colega
que se llama carmen que tiene una niña
con síndrome de dawn decidimos por qué
no hacer este experimento y resulta que
el experimento dio muy buenos resultados
y nace en la casa de correr lo está en
honor a esa niña ahora bien vamos a
contarles un poco de que cuál es nuestra
historia hoy esta va a ser una charla
muy anecdótica muy muy interesante y
empieza con esto empieza con dos
personajes empieza con dos personajes
que representan a todo un equipo
sebastián giraldo estudiante como todos
y nelson correa diseñador como muchos
esto era la vida de antes de casa de
carlota dos personajes que existían que
eran muy dinámicos que hacían muchas
cosas pero que la vida les cambió
completamente como todo un equipo de
trabajo se bastó antes de casa de
carlota donde estabas
con antes que estoy estoy estudiando
artes en artes es cierto 6 y ahorita qué
haces ahora
ahorita que yo que estoy haciendo estoy
trabajando de caza en calor está y por
qué que te gusta casa de carlota pasar
rico para bueno y queremos mover la
carrerita y para yo estoy trabajando y
para qué porque estamos trabajando
porque estamos pasando bueno tener
pláticas y nosotros queremos que
contrates de trabajo que nos contraten
ese es nuestro valor fundamental
nosotros no estamos no somos una
fundación no trabajamos para que nos
apoyen sino para que nos den
oportunidades de mostrar un talento
diferente no estamos vendiendo ni
lástima no estamos vendiendo ni es que
pobrecitos que trabajan con chicos con
él nadie sea esto es sin lástima esto es
un proyecto comercial que en este
momento es autosostenible que está
generando recursos y que cada uno tiene
una remuneración por su trabajo igual se
va y yo y el equipo que está detrás
entonces aquí empezamos con dos personas
que no se conocían y que eran
serio serio pues que éramos personas que
vienen ahora que somos ayunas y llegan
al estilo y hay otras que lo pierden es
muy interesante porque es que antes en
el en el este era estresado era
confundido era se intimidaba con todo y
ahorita está en la capacidad de burlarse
de sí mismo sobre todo ver la vida
completamente diferente porque no estoy
buscando que sebastián sea como yo no es
que yo volví como él o nosotros volvemos
como él nos estamos discapacitado
estamos tratando de pensar como piensa
sebastián como piensas jordan que piensa
manuel a cómo piensa a simón cuánta y
santiago que son chicos con otras formas
de ver la vida diferente que son los que
estaban atrás si uno se va si está
contento si sigue contento y usted a mí
estar aquí no
[Música]
vamos hombre
es un galán ya les dijo tiene síndrome
dancing o síndrome galán caballero y
príncipe
listo pues ya ven aquí ya saben quién es
la calaña de personaje que es l
pasamos entonces para contar un poquito
esta experiencia les queremos mostrar un
poco el día a día de casa de carlota ojo
por ojo mira como sordo es una mirada
muy diferentes de sebastián y como ellos
empiezan a hacer ilustraciones imágenes
que nosotros después potencializa vamos
para producto y para servicios para
campañas páginas web empaques y lo que
sea pero la mirada completamente
diferente es cómo está estos genios
empiezan a mostrarnos que la vida puede
ser diferente que las metodologías de
trabajo son distintas que no hay que
torturar sí que no hay que empezar a
generar ideas absurdas o que nos tenemos
que empezar a formar alguna otra cosa
para generar ideas no es desde la
espontaneidad es de aquí adentro que
nace la real creatividad y todos ustedes
pueden ser tan creativos como como ellos
todos podemos ser muy creativos porque
miramos adentro
seamos pues más creativo que los demás
sebas es natural él no está tan y está
tan contaminado con muchas cosas y ahí
se va si el resto del equipo
entonces este por ejemplo deducciones
como esta
esta la hizo jordan ciertos de nuestros
compañeros un chico de 24 años que tiene
autismo resulta que este dibujo que sale
de un taller un día a día de casa de
carlota tiene una esposa especial y es
es un dinosaurio obvio todo lo en
dinosaurio pero tiene cinco patas y
resulta que esas cinco patas no es
porque él se equivocó ante la educación
convencional sería una equivocación
porque los dinosaurios muchos tienen
cuatro otros en dos pero resulta que
éste tiene cual éste tiene cinco ethan
coen la razón porque es que él quiere
correr más rápido para exhibir y
extinguirse tan rápido es una y es su
mentalidad es su paralelo es su
mentalidad diferente la que nos enseña y
nos muestra que las realidades pueden
ser diversas y que el pensamiento puede
ser de otra forma es cierto
y no solamente hacen estéticas vamos a
grabar estas sino cómo piensan los
chicos como sebastián esta es su forma
de hablar hay agencias de publicidad en
que les dicen piense diferente le pagan
a un copy para que piense en este la
forma en que ellos hablan y son
respuestas a preguntas básicas qué es la
felicidad para nosotros la felicidad
sería como irnos de viaje montar en
bicicleta o tener plática también ser
dogmática para chiqui a las chicas
la felicidad de estar en la felicidad es
estar en la tierra en la tierra y en las
nubes a la vez eso es brutal
o sea eso es un tema de una campaña para
una marca gigantesca de bebida cierto o
pues soy diferente porque siempre cambio
de ropa el se considera es una frase de
sebastián ya él no es diferente porque
tiene síndrome de tano porque se cambia
la ropa como cada uno de ustedes todos
somos diferentes
quiero cambiar porque no quiero ser el
mismo toda la vida o para ser una
princesa hay que leer es un copy de una
de nuestras creativas que le preguntamos
para hacer si piensa que hay que hacer y
para ella no es universidad eso sí no
ni ponerse corona sino que para ellas
es leer es brutal esto para una campaña
de de motivación a la lectura para
jóvenes es impresionante
o para hacer prisas
esto es algo de la carrera y para bailar
para bailar esto que ustedes ven a
continuación ustedes puedan decir ay si
tan lindo los dibujos de niños estos y
esto termina siendo como un papel que
puede terminar en la basura pero eso
para nosotros aunque cambiamos la forma
de pensar para los directivos de casa de
carlota los directores creativos está
para nota es algo súper valioso y súper
poderoso esto que parece un dibujo de
niños termina siendo la imagen para una
bebida energética muy famosa en el mundo
entonces es la forma de cambiar el punto
de vista de las cosas
esto es un ejercicio muy rápido de como
diseñadores como yo convencionales o
diseñados con síndrome de chicos con
autismo podrían podrían enfrentar este
proyecto de marca de branding resulta
que para un diseñador estás contento si
esto para un diseñador convencional
cuando yo le pido a ellos venga hágame
un diseño un logotipo
el diseñador convencional lo que hace es
irse al computador y empezar a buscar
tipografías qué es lo que está de moda
en pinter es que está de moda en eeuu en
europa si no eso lo podemos hacer
cualquiera pero para un diseñador con el
síndrome de down en ellos no van a mirar
al computador se vas nunca va a mirar el
computador a ver qué es lo que está
pasando no el diseño desde su
conocimiento de lo que él sabe desde que
él empieza a experimentar y expresarse
esto es un diseño yo nunca había visto
diseñadores tanto los que puedan diseñar
tantas tipografías en una sentada como
sebastián o como juan david o como
jordan en una sola sentada
es impresionante entonces este tipo de
cosas baratos son súper valiosas un
chico con autismo
y la mente puede llegar a hacer esto y
esto pasó le dijimos diseñé esta marca y
este personaje lo que hizo fue llenar
una hoja de pliego completa x palito x
palito y para él decía h haré lo que es
el tipo de uva que se usa para este tipo
de bebida entonces es muy interesante
como esto para nosotros super valioso
para una agencia convencional sería un
error y llíria hermano cierre eso esto
no sirve vuelve a empezar para esto para
nosotros es súper valioso y termina
siendo el diseño de una marca de
botellas de empaques entonces la forma
de diseñar de un chico con síndrome down
y la forma de diseñar de un chico con
autismo entonces ahí empezamos a cambiar
paradigmas lo que aparentemente es un
error termina siendo algo muy valioso
para nosotros una estética que vende
mucho sino porque se vende
esto
en el reino el reino el reino que no es
un reino para un chico con síndrome de
perdón para un chico con autismo esto no
es un reino para nosotros tener un reino
de navidad cierto esto para un chico con
autismo es un caballo con un árbol en la
cabeza y no solamente no luego a
nosotros y se lo validamos se lo válido
al gerente general de una gran compañía
internacional que se van a dar cuenta
por el color
un diseñador hace un cambio estamos
hablando de cambios cierto hace un
cambio de color
aquí apretaditos son muy ricos
de relojes
nervioso no jamás jamás me gusta resulta
que esto termina siendo una campaña un
empaque de una gran compañía es con una
mirada completamente diferente aquí
viene una anécdota muy bacana resulta
que cuando fue presentar el proyecto en
el diseñador con out y con un autismo le
dijo al gerente el gerente le hai tan
lindo el reyno de navidad no es en los
señores uno es un reno esto es un
caballo con un árbol en la cabeza y eso
quedó dentro del empaque cierto segunda
anécdota del mismo se ganó un premio
cuando fuimos a recibir el premio estaba
un auditorio lleno de diseñar imagínate
lleno de ego lleno de todos
yo quiero yo quiero ganarme el concurso
no sé que cuando el presentador que
estaba en esto empezó a decir bueno y
los ganadores del mejor empaque de este
año es casa de carlota
entonces claro mi colega que es el otro
director llegue le dice al chico con
síndrome down autismo vayan reciban el
premio los chicos se bajan la gente
estaba aplaudiendo los chicos suben aquí
estaba el presentador del concurso con
el premio en la mano y al fondo habían
dos personas
los chicos subieron pasaron derecho
dejar al presentador con el premio en la
mano y se pueden donde las chicas
modelos que estaban en el escenario
porque querían tomarse la foto con las
modelos
no espero que tu chica que te gustaría
premio chicas y chicas
claro
ahora sí porque estos chicos no viven en
el pasado no vienen en el futuro no
dicen adiós que yo quiero ganarme ese
premio porque quiero ser más importante
que el otro porque quiero que me
contraten más para ellos es el hoy y el
ahora y eso es maravilloso
o sea eso es maravilloso porque porque
si empezamos a pensar lo que pasa no nos
ganamos el premio no yo primero tomamos
las fotos con las chicas y esta razón el
premio fácil claro entonces bueno esto
esto es una reunión de trabajo después
obviamente con mucho respeto termina
haciendo que seas muy exitoso aquí en
medellín termina cargando o sea hay un
cambio porque de verdad es un paradigma
de que no se puede tocar al cliente
o esto o esto cuando sea más conocido el
alcalde de medellín que llega el alcalde
le dice se presentó como aquí síndrome
down syndrome de galán caballero y
principio de méxico el alcalde y ex
príncipe de méxico como que principio de
médico antes te gusta el tequila que ley
este que no me gusta whisky degustar
lewis y llega el alcalde y le dice pero
como así se hizo del principio de médico
te gusta el tequila y de no no wins king
el whisky y después y el alcalde seguía
pero como así no te exentos del
aguardiente antioqueño y sebas todo se
le dice luis quien louis y como se le
niega tres veces a un alcalde sólo
sebastián pero porque supera ese súper
decidido a lo que él quiere y él lo
quiere aparentar más
otro también estuvimos en washington
hace dos meses se fue a vida a dibujar
la patrulla de un policía de la casa
blanca o sea a quien se le acercó
publicidad de casablanca más paranoico
no puede ser y porque quería ir a
dibujar le la patrulla al señor y le
dijo déjame dibujar de hoja artiles ya
no yo no me puedo casar de para para que
me dibujes dibújame si quiere yo voy
caminando y él iba detrás del policía
capitán del policía cuando tenía miedo
ya no tiene prejuicio en nada sino listo
sigamos o cuando fuimos a nuestra
primera conferencia internacional de
diseño en bogotá le pregunté no tenías
mí de mi ser mira de qué por qué
hay 1200 personas en el escenario ojalá
hubieran más
esa es la gran diferencia yo antes
quiero amor todo el resto aquí estoy
súper tranquilo porque porque estoy con
él porque me estoy discapacitado
y hace dos meses estuvimos en washington
hablando de políticas de inclusión para
personas con discapacidad esto no
hubiera sido nunca posible porque porque
es que esto es una cosa mirada fuimos a
empresa que fue ejemplo y mira nos
sentamos en el suelo al frente había un
montón de ejecutivos en washington pero
la espontaneidad es ser como uno somos y
nos sentamos en piso y propuesta del
hombre eso es genial empezamos a cambiar
los paradigmas esto que aparentemente
rápidamente imagínense un corazón como
es un corazón sí o no
llegamos al mismo símbolo esto para una
chica con síndrome down es un corazón y
yo le decía esto no es un corazón ese ha
sido un corazón y yo he llegado a hacer
esto y eso es un corazón si es un
corazón
madre mía qué hago con esta niña si es
un corazón y terminas con eso
gente que empieza por una forma
diferente o un carro y eso es un corazón
de sebastián cuál es la razón de
sebastián para ser rápidos y porque los
corazones no deben ser en punta para que
no se caigan y no se quiebre el corazón
es brutal y en la sociedad y en la razón
de sebastián
esto imagínense cómo es un carro no sé
cómo de un carro siempre dibujamos el
carro de perfil cierto partimos con
síndrome on en europa y acá un carro es
esto
esto y esto es una mirada cenital
cambiar no es la misma fachada es la
mirada superior de un vehículo porque es
como él está sentado en el carro y lo ve
todo perimetralmente es un cambio de una
mirada diferente
este es el carro de washington de la
patrulla
me gusta dibujar todo es impresionante
es una mirada diferente desde arriba
entonces es como empezamos nosotros
darle valor a eso que normalmente no
tendría valor es la mirada sebastián de
buscarlo en washington y te dio miedo no
nunca
entonces ya para ir finalizando en
colombia hay 1.4 millones de personas
con discapacidad en colombia del 12% se
encuentra trabajando y el 80 de ese 12
prevén trabajar sin contrato laboral y
el 7 tiene un contrato a término fijo
el porcentaje muy poquito de personas
que están siendo contratadas si es casi
mínimo en casa de carlota tenemos a 6
chicos trabajando y queremos que esto
crezca porque porque es que estos
pelados son muy pesos y muy creativos y
sobre todo nos están cambiando la forma
de ver la vida yo no sé no me ahora
parado aquí tan fácilmente si no era
conocido y sebastián a manuel a jordan y
que a ellos les damos ese homenaje ya
estamos aquí parados por el equipo
completo no es el no es hoy yo es el
equipo completo y para terminar los
quiero dejar con estos textos que muy
lindos pero muy interesantes hicimos una
campaña para una entidad de innovación
en medellín y espero para lo que para
ellos que es la innovación para nosotras
la innovación es el celular para
nosotros es el computador para ellos
innovaciones y no innovaciones volverá a
ser caballero
y no va a hacer es no quedarse callado
tal innovación es no romper el corazón a
las mujeres es les gusta más de una
afición a innovar a hacer las cosas
diferentes y nuevas innovar es volver a
saludar a las personas estamos tan
pegados del celular que necesitamos
saludando y no estamos hablando con las
personas variar es como disfrutar y la
mejor para mí es la innovación de la uti
farrah no está en el centro está en
sabaneta
chicos muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]